M1 Abrams de ce type seront livrés par
les États-Unis à l'Ukraine d'ici la fin
du mois des chars qui seront accompagnés
de livraison de munitions à l'uranium
appauvri ces obus sont capables de
perforer les blindages mais sont
controversés en raison des risques
toxiques pour les populations et les
militaires la fourniture de ces armes
fait partie d'une aide d'un milliard de
dollars supplémentaires annoncé par le
secrétaire d'État américain Anthony
blinken lors de sa visite à Kiev une
décision que fustige le Kremlin selon
Moscou il s'agit d'un signe clair de
l'inhumanité des États-Unis
ceci est une très mauvaise nouvelle
leur utilisation au cours de l'histoire
récente en Europe en Yougoslavie a eu de
très très graves conséquences
la responsabilité un combat entièrement
aux États-Unis
des munitions à l’uranium appauvris
avait été massivement utilisée lors des
bombardements de l'OTAN en Nexus la vie
en 1999 ainsi que des guerres du Golfe
de 1990 et 2003 une utilisation qui
n'est pas interdite par le droit
international mais selon de nombreux
experts l'ingestion ou l'inhalation de
poussière d'uranium appauvri peut
provoquer des malformations génitales et
des cancers